thousands of protesters for the Michigan
State's Capitol over the governor's
stay-at-home order listen instead of
looking at essential and non-essential
let's start looking at what's safe and
unsafe and start getting people back to
work florentine is for the sick healthy
it's time to open up we're gonna take
our liberties and we're gonna keep them
and we're gonna fight for them the order
is the strictest in the nation with
pushes back on family visits came go to
your own summer house can't use a jet
ski can use a motorboat but can use a
canoe let's bring in the host hello
Bertie file Fox on Fox Nation Judge
Andrew Napolitano judge this these
restrictions are ridiculous and
thousands of people came out to protest
does it surprise you it surprises me
that the took them this long to come out
Brian good morning it's always good to
be on with you even if we're so far
apart from each other
this is a blatant violation of the Bill
of Rights a blatant violation of freedom
of assembly of your right to purchase a
product that you decide is is essential
if you go to a big box store in Michigan
and you decide instead of buying cereal
I wanna buy grass seed instead of buying
paper towels I wanna buy a garden hose
you have violated her the governor's
executive order and theoretically
because she's threatened to do this
she'll shut down the big-box store
because they sold you grass seed and a
garden hose instead of cereal and paper
towels these are not decisions for the
government to make these are decisions
for individuals to make and the sooner
we take our freedoms back the less
likely the government will be able to
continue doing this and if we just take
our freedoms back they might not come
back I know and it's really getting
tough now because it wasn't the only
place through a protest but let me just
see we letting you let everybody here
with the growth governor said quote we
question some restrictions ago this is
the governor Whitmer has imposed as
overstepping her authority this is
according to the protester she has
created a vague framework of emergency
laws that only confuse Michigan citizens
as a result will not have strict
enforcement of these orders so they're
not going to comply guess
or else they're protesting they're
protesting in Kentucky Ohio North
Carolina and Virginia and as more and
more states go online and get their
rights back that is going to fuel I
believe other states to go wait a second
this is getting ridiculous
you got 29 states without big with
without a big imprint from this virus
don't you think that's where it's
heading judge I do think that's where it
where it's heading you know here in New
Jersey the governor boasts it boasted
the carpet tucker carlson last night the
Bill of Rights is above my pay grade
the bill's rights is above your pay
grade you took a solemn oath to preserve
protect and defend the Constitution of
the United States which includes the
Bill of Rights
when these governors try to write law
rather than enforce law that the
legislature is written they violate the
Federal Constitution that violated the
state constitution and in the case of
governor Murphy in New Jersey who says
the Bill of Rights is above his pay
grade that's the felony of misconduct in
office didn't each civil offense either
knowingly or negligently crushed civil
liberties as these governors in and
judge 10 seconds I feel bad for law
enforcement they have to enforce these
ridiculous rules your thumb Ryan I have
spoken I have spoken to cops they hate
what the governors are making them do
most of the cops that I've smoked their
hearts are with got to judge